the following graph represents the first
five terms of two given patterns in the
answer box there are different
statements about the two patterns choose
all correct statements so here for each
point this point right over here this
represents its horizontal coordinate is
the first term of pattern a which is
four and it's a vertical coordinate is
the first term in pattern B which is one
and then we could do that for the other
points as well so actually let's figure
out what the values are so we have
pattern a and then we have pattern B so
the first term for pattern a is four and
when pet that first when pattern a is
for the first term for pattern B is one
the second term for pattern a is 7 and
when pattern a is 7 pattern B is also 7
third term pattern a is 10 and pattern B
is 13 and then fourth term pattern a is
pattern a is 13 and pattern B is 19 and
then finally fifth term pattern a is 16
is 16 and pattern B and pattern B is 25
now before even looking at these let's
see what we can think about these
patterns here so it looks like pattern a
starts at 4 and it increases by 3 every
time to go from one term to the next you
just have to add just have to add 3 now
what about for pattern B well pattern B
starts at 1 and every term here it looks
like you're adding 6 when pattern a
increases by 3 and we're moving in the
horizontal direction the base based on
the fact that pattern a is on represent
on the horizontal axis we're going to
move up 6 in the vertical axis and we
see that here pattern a increases by 3
pattern a increases by 3 from one term
to the next and when that increased by 3
pattern B increased by 6 from one term
to the next pattern B increased by 6
from one term to the next and we see
that it keeps it keeps it keeps doing
that
now let's think about what we have over
here to see which of these statements
actually apply to this for every term in
pattern a multiply the term by 2 and
then subtract 7 to get the corresponding
term from pattern B so let's see with
that let's see if that holds up so
according to this if this was true I
should be able take this multiplied by 2
and subtract 7 and get that so let's see
is 1 equal to 2 times 8 minus 7 or sorry
2 times 4 minus 7 so 2 times this number
2 times 4 minus 7 well 8 minus 7 is
equal to 1 is this right over here equal
to 2 times this 7 minus 7 well yeah it's
equal to 7 is 13 equal to 2 times 10 2
times 10 minus 7 yeah 20 minus 7 is 13
is 19 equal to 2 times 13 minus 7 26
minus 7 is 19 is 25 equal to 2 times 16
minus 7 well 32 minus minus 7 is 25 so
this first statement checks out for the
corresponding term the value of pattern
B is 2 times the value of pattern a
minus 7 now let's look at the second one
the terms of pattern B are always
greater than or equal to their
corresponding terms from pattern a well
no that's not right it's true for a
couple of scenarios here for the third
fourth and fifth term or actually for
the second third and fourth second third
fourth and fifth terms pattern B is
equal to or greater than pattern a but
for the first term it's not true pattern
a is greater so this is not this is not
right to get from each point to the next
you need to move three units to the
right and 6 units up well that's exactly
what we talked about from one term to
the next pattern a along our horizontal
axis we increase by three while pattern
B we increase which is plotted on our
vertical axis by six so you move three
to the right and six up so that is right
the second terms of both patterns are 7
well yeah we see that right over here
the second terms are 7 we have 7 here
and we have seven there and so that is
right as well so the only one that
doesn't apply is this second one this is
not right